so one of the questions I could ask
quite often is what happened to the
Greek gods and goddesses why did they
disappear so suddenly with no
explanation there are some interesting
theories but in reality the answer is
far less exciting and honestly slightly
disappointing
there was no epic war to end all wars
there was no Ragnarok like event to
signal the world being reborn the Greek
deities were slowly phased out by
Christianity and eventually forgotten by
the Greek people it's easy to forget
that these stories of Greek myth that we
look at today were more than just a set
of stories they once made up the primary
religion of ancient Greece long before
Christianity ever did the fall of these
Greek deities follows a pattern that
we've seen across numerous countries
Christianity and other religions
bulldoze their way across the land and
through a series of smear campaigns they
demonize the worship of all other
deities and this is something we've seen
of Greek Roman Norse Celtic and Slavic
deities just to name a few
throughout ancient Greece there has
always been a major cult to a period of
time when the people would partake in
the worship of these deities whether it
was the Mycenaeans the Minoans the
Orphic or even the Hellenistic period
but this worship was always contested
even before Christianity spread to
Greece the several scholars openly
criticized the worship of these deities
with the first being Xena phonies who
criticized the gods human vices and this
is something that definitely contributed
to their downfall
even Plato believed there was one
Supreme God one example of perfection in
the universe that he named the form of
the good so with this metaphorical fire
of descent already burning the arrival
of st. Paul and Christianity in 49 ad
then further stoked the flames disbelief
and crisis of faith spread across the
country like wildfire to many of us
today who have become bored with the
idea of one omniscient perfect deity
Greek mythology and many others provide
us with an interesting set of
alternatives a set of deities who behave
quite similar to us a set of stories
that we can some way relate to however
this argument was definitely one of the
Christians most powerful tools in terms
of tearing down other mythologies and
systems of belief st. Augustine and
other Christian philosophers would often
ask the question if these were higher
beings worthy of worship then why do
they act out of pettiness and jealousy
now when you couple this with the fact
that those refusing to convert to
Jannetty were hunted down and killed you
have a fairly compelling argument to
forget about Zeus and coal and adapt
this new religion these old gods never
really went anywhere
people just raised us Greek Orthodox
under a Christian belief system and
we've talked of these old gods been seen
as a punishable sin they just faded into
obscurity in recent years there has been
somewhat of a resurgence in the belief
as well as the interest in Greek deities
and this ultimately comes down to us
becoming a more secular society we can
now discuss these ancient religions and
mythologies without fear of being burned
at a stake at least in most countries
there's no doubt that pop culture has
played its part in helping raise
interest in these deities whether it's
in the form of comics and books or
movies and TV we've even seen a rise in
Hellenistic neo-paganism since the early
90s which is now once again a recognized
religion in Greece even before
Christianity spread its way across
Greece the worship of these gods had
always been debated and contested
similar to how today people still
dismiss these deities because they
believe their behavior to be immoral as
someone who runs a channel that mostly
discusses mythology I've definitely had
my fair share of people telling me that
I need to stop what I'm doing because
all you're doing is spreading the word
of the devil because I simply discuss
these stories Christianity may not have
been the entire reason the Greek gods
were forgotten but it definitely was the
nail in the coffin for many mythologies
and religions unfortunately Greek
mythology was so well documented that we
were able to recover a portion of what
was lost sadly that's a fate that many
other mythologies did not share so to
answer the question of where did the
Greek gods go know where they were once
part of the primary religion in ancient
Greece until they were replaced by
Christianity and eventually forgotten
that is until the rise of Greek
mythology which now gives these deities
the spotlight once again however whether
you believe these deities were real and
whether you choose the worship them is
an entirely different story
[Music]